Steve Martin a big influence on you I
love Steve Martin as a kid I mean I I
and as an adult but I used to listen to
his albums over and over again and you
know him and David Letterman I think
were my biggest influences growing up
and pee-wee Herman you've mentioned
Letterman a lot as an influence on you
our parents didn't get a lot of what let
me share the same parents but we were
brothers
we should have mentioned that at the top
the parents of our generation didn't
always understand what Letterman was
doing when he was very late night and
doing jokes that suddenly felt like the
same things we and our friends were
doing when we were making fun of
traditional entertainment do you feel
like there are still people who don't
quite understand the irony of what
you're going for with your comedy yeah I
mean when I was a teenager the fact that
David Letterman was making fun of
everything he was making fun of TV he
was making fun of just the idea of doing
a celebrity interview he would never
take those interviews seriously if you
watch his share interviewers his Madonna
interview he wasn't taking it seriously
he wasn't asking serious questions that
just really appealed to a kid I'm
describing myself so stay with me but a
kid who is an outsider and who didn't
really view the world as serious that
just appealed to me so much and and so I
like to think that what I do is kind of
continuing in that tradition where a kid
will see it and go oh wow I don't take
the world seriously and I think that
this is all stupid and and that's what I
do with my stuff too is I I try to make
everyone see how stupid all this
actually is